it's Valentine's Day 2020 and I'm about
to propose to my girlfriend she has zero
idea it's coming okay I'm rehearsing
doing a little practice so Valentine's
Day is not as as special here is what
you're saying yes I would say that this
is just not a child a beach is cool and
in trouble Sansa holidays okay because
I'm trying to make the day special I'm
trying to make Valentine's memories
[Applause]
okay trying to find the perfect location
to do this out of the wind
he is she's up there doesn't know what's
going on yeah I just said we're doing a
nice little picnic
we should be luck framing the shot is
this good I think this is good
it'd be more like this like this
she's like this
yeah it's like check it out
rocks are like
I get like little knives
yeah
just do a video for our parents to show
Valentine
[Music]
the last three years and the most
beautiful
and you show me what
really can be and you make me a better
person
for that
my soul mate
I was just in the rocks and I found the
kinder kinder surprise
I want to spend the rest of my life with
you
[Music]
that's faster
that would have fantastic
[Music]
okay so
he said yes
we're getting married
I'm like in the fog
[Music]